here now is brett tulman he's a former
u.s attorney and executive director of
right on crime he was also a very senior
counsel in the senate judiciary uh
committee uh once upon a time brett
thanks so much for joining us this whole
idea of a special master uh
you're going to know a whole lot more
about this than i am but weren't you
supposed to appoint a special master
before you do the raid not after you've
read all the documents
yeah i mean this is this is something
that is making the department of justice
very uncomfortable jason because
typically they like to keep all of this
in-house they have a review team called
a taint team that will review documents
that they seized to make sure they
didn't seize anything that was
privileged
then you have the trump
lawyers filing a motion for a special
master why are they uncomfortable
they're uncomfortable because they
always keep the decisions the review the
reports after the review all internal
there's never an outside objective third
party that is looking at it this is a
move i have not seen in 20 plus years in
the criminal justice system jason this
is the the potential appointment of an
outsider a third party that's objective
who's going to look at what they did and
that's why you're seeing the discomfort
in doj
i also want to note that the attorney
general late tonight fired a shot really
across the bow warning the department
and potential whistleblowers about
communications with congress now brett i
can tell you i was the chairman of the
oversight committee and i felt like i
had free and full access for any
government employee to come talk to the
oversight committee and members of
congress in our committee but for them
at this timing to send this shot across
the bow means hey
we're watching you and uh i i thought
that the timing of this was highly
suspicious seven page memo
warning people about their talk and
their interaction with people like
senator grassley or senator johnson
yeah be very very weary of
a a government
leader
who tells its people they cannot talk to
other outside government entities
especially those that exercise oversight
now it's one thing to say and they've
had a long-standing policy at doj that
you cannot interact with legislators on
bills or on things you know
legislation but it's very different to
be sending this shot out right now after
they know that senator grassley and jim
jordan in the house
has been approached by whistleblowers
indicating that there's far too many
political political decisions being made
at doj and at the highest levels this
should be very scary for all of us for
merrick garland to come out and tell his
people on the eve of what we now know
that they cannot talk to outside people
yeah i mean this is literally just a
couple of days since this story and you
think about the the wheels that have to
spin there in order to generate this
type of
a memo it really does have the
appearance that is in direct
relationship to whistleblowers going out
and talking to to members of congress uh
last comment here brett i want to get
your reaction there allegedly or
supposedly there might be documents that
the fbi sees that are covered by
attorney-client privilege how does the
department justify and deal with this
type of thing if there truly are
personal communications that the
president was entitled to have as
attorney-client privilege
yeah no question they are supposed to be
sensitive to that from the very
beginning this
search warrant the execution of it it
does not appear that they were sensitive
to the issue going in and then they also
sent a very strong signal that they were
not really considering executive
privilege that's a privilege that
applies to the president and his
communications and it is a valid
significant privilege so the department
of justice is caught on their heels now
trying to show a different face and a
different narrative that they've been
thoughtful on this issue they haven't
and that's why this judge is considering
the special master bret tolman thank you
for joining us this evening hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else